it's just casserole who is a second year
graduate student actually a fourth year
I just need to update my website student
at UCSD with daniela muchacho and and
she will tell us about ring packing and
amortized fuel bootstrapping so i wanna
remind remind everyone all the attendees
again but if you have questions you can
type into the Q&A interface all right um
so thank you Vinod very much for the
introduction as well as all of the other
workshop organizers thank you to
everyone on zoom' for sticking around
for last talk so right now I'll be
talking about joint work with my advisor
Daniele on speeding up queue
bootstrapping so I guess before we get
into it I sort of want to give you an
idea of where we're going
so we'll be presenting a new fast
algorithm for bootstrapping about Lu
nearly many cipher texts of the four and
output by the homomorphic NAND gates of
so to you homomorphic encryption scheme
ilaria mentions many people have
mentioned as well that was presented by
Leo and Daniel II so you're more
specific for each of these ciphertexts
will have to spend about lambda to the
epsilon many homework operations for the
refreshing procedure or again lambda is
a security perimeter and epsilon is some
sort of constants you can take to the
less than or equal to 1/2 and notably
this is a savings of almost a linear
factor over encryption schemes from
similar assumptions where when I say
similar assumptions I'm comparing to
other homomorphic encryption schemes
where security is based on the hardness
or some lattice problem or approximating
some lattice problem do it in polynomial
approximation factors this is an
important sort of distinction to make
because if we're willing to make
somewhat stronger assumptions or take
larger parameters there they're do
already exists wholly homomorphic
encryption schemes that I had Polliwog
like herniated one morphic operations
but they they require assuming hardness
quasi rocks meeting these sons problems
through the quasi polynomial factors so
we're sort of comparing ourselves to the
the polynomial machine here we also have
to make an additional assumption you can
see my cursor which is circular security
this is pretty common for fully
homomorphic encryption schemes sense to
perform this bootstrapping operation
we're talking about in a minute we'll
need to handover encryptions of our
secret key just some sort of untrusted
party so we're assuming that this is
going to compromise security so that's
where we're going is that instead of
poly log you get lambda to the epsilon
for some epsilon and on the other hand
you have polynomial assumptions is
supposed to pass a polynomial right I'm
sorry
the advantage is that you have
polynomial assumptions is supposed to
quasi-polynomial like just for example
but on the other hand uuuu the amortized
cost is the lambda to the epsilon as
opposed to poly log lambda yes that's
correct
yes so yeah we're getting sub linear
we're not getting all the way down to
the poly log but we we make weaker
assumptions the trade-offs and the
epsilon somehow it you know it comes up
somewhere else in the you know something
grows with Epsilon so when you talk
about like how we're actually gonna be
performing the bootstrapping
there are some trade-offs that you can
make between let's say like error and
efficiency for different choices of
epsilon but it'll always be some sort of
constant thanks for the clarify
questions okay so I'm not gonna bother
with I think that's been covered by the
previous speakers so I'm just gonna sort
of launch right into specifically it's a
few homomorphic encryption scheme as
well as few bootstrapping and after
we've talked about that since we're sort
of taking this as a starting point for
our for our new bootstrapping algorithm
well we'll go into you know what's
what's new in this paper
so Leo and Daniel I give a very fast
homomorphic and gate
that takes takes as inputs lwe
encryptions so here's the LDV that we
all know and love so sort of relevant to
point out that here on parameterizing
bikie which is our plaintext modulus
space you will often think of em as
being you know the bits 0 or 1 in which
case T is equal to 2 and so we're sort
of scaling up our message by this factor
if you will need to tweak this a little
bit but everything's pretty much much
standard and this few mandates will take
in encryptions of two bits and again we
have sort of plain text modulus of four
here but usually can still just think of
m0 and one is being bits and outputs a
note of your encryption of the result of
this NAND gate under the plaintext
modulus and I wanted to sort of show
just the actual formula for this NAND
gate not because they think that we
should all like stare this and convince
ourselves that it actually computes them
and to within some sort of error that's
tolerated by the encryption scheme but
just to sort of emphasize that this is
an extremely fast and lightweight
operation especially in terms of
operations this is just a couple of
vacations and additions of vectors and
dimensions and integers multi so we can
reform exactly one of these and
operations before we have to start
worrying about error right so you've
sort of approximately computed NAND here
so we introduced an error in our
computation and we've also added the
error turns our cipher texts and so
we're going to see error growths and
we'll need to do something to reduce
this so we can continue performing or
NAND gates on this should come as no
surprise that we'll be doing you
strapping so - so it's trapping it's a
really cool idea introduced by each
entry in 2009 and the basic idea is that
we're just going to
work with you valuates decryption
function to be a little bit more
specific about this since we are going
to be giving sort of explicit
bootstrapping scheme our decryption
function is a function sort of straight
so it takes in a secret key and a cipher
text and often in non homomorphic
encryption will sort of think of this as
being like a partially applied function
where it's already been applied to the
key as an input and so it just remains
to like take a ciphertext to compute
decryption but we're for the purposes of
homomorphic evaluation going to
partially apply in the other order so
we're going to sort of partially apply
the decryption function to a ciphertext
and then we'll take energy as arguments
and this will be the function that we
want to homomorphic reevaluate so then
the sort of syntax of a homomorphic
evaluation function will give us that if
we give us and put this function as well
as some encryptions of the key material
that we've used to encrypt the
ciphertext that the results should be a
valid encryption of this function
applied to its inputs and therefore the
encryption of our cipher text right so
what does this mean this means that we
get a new fresh ciphertext it's still a
valid encryption and what was reduced
error it is reduced error if the error
of her head for this homomorphic
evaluation of the decryption function is
actually lower than what the error for
the plaintiff isn't so in order for this
to work out we are going to need some
sort of encryption scheme that's
powerful enough to evaluate lwe
decryption again without exceeding its
own sort of error threshold right it's
not going to help us at all if we remove
you know we sort of perform this
decryption but then we end up with an
encryption that doesn't guarantee
correctness of decryption so to does
this they show how to use the
homomorphic encryption scheme of
Gentry's to high on waters GSW to encode
there is
these one more forehand gates into sort
of a cryptographic register shall I call
I got homomorphic each emulator and
we'll use these accumulators to evaluate
decryption so I just wanna like draw a
little cartoon about what this is gonna
look like give us an idea maybe some
concerns we're gonna have when we try to
speed up the process so we have to all
do music projects with sort of moderate
error I've tried to indicate how how
much error is inherent in ciphertext
with the intensity of this red color so
you perform our NAND gate and we get a
very noisy I'll do a cipher text
including results now to refresh the
ciphertext we're going to first encode
it into a noiseless homomorphic
accumulator based on the GS w scheme and
we're also going to have to play with
some accumulators encoding our our key
that we used that we're refreshing and
we can use these registers to evaluate
exhibit we can sort of like process
these registers to end up with
encryptions of every term is the inner
product that we need to compute forty
version so we'll just subtract off these
turns from the register that's holding
our cipher text value rings in this
process we introduce some error into the
sort of outer layer of decryption we do
this for every entry of the inner
product and now we have a somewhat noisy
register
that's encrypting the the term sort of
like the minus eight is straight and
infection so these registers will also
support the scaling and rounding
operation that we'll need to perform for
lgbtq christian and they also support a
cipher text extraction operation so that
we can get from this this accumulator
and elderly ciphertext with
noise it's gonna be comparable to the
noise in the GSW encryption so this is
great so now we have an LD new a cipher
text with lower error one of the results
we can continue performing names on the
cipher text coupon bootstrapping after
every and and we have a fully again this
is going to be sort of contingent on the
the error not going too much over this
whole you know bootstrapping process if
we have very large overhead and things
and we'll need to take a much larger
ratio modulus to error and so this is
sort of where the stronger assumptions
that we might need to make come into
play with my need to take larger
parameters to be guaranteed observable
security you know you said you know the
bootstrapping process it takes to mod
for cipher text and converts it to a
more to cipher text or rather the pre
bootstrapping stacked right in the next
step so so and then you take that which
you very noisy cipher text is what comes
out of it then you take it put it into
this gist of your bootstrapping process
and out comes a mod for cipher text of
the result yes so thank you again for
the clarifying question we'll be able to
extract from this a an LTV cipher text
of the appropriate one with yeah sort of
error bound that we needs to be able to
perform and gate and as well as a
propertyless view gives this fast on one
more date that's just you know additions
of protections and additions you also
show how to build these leaders from the
GSW scheme bootstrapping and if you take
seven year many operations on these
emitters and really induces polynomial
error overhead so we're in sort of
polynomial error version which is great
so we want to do better than this right
we want to get down to sublinear many
more accumulator operations and an issue
you can see we just tried to do this for
a single ciphertext is that there's
really no way around looking at every
single entry of that inner product rate
we need to compute it inner product
between our secret key and the
ciphertext mask a to be able to perform
decryption and so we sort of yeah have
to have to perform n of these regions
and that sort of motivates our approach
which is parallel right so we're just
going to try to amortize this I will be
able to get so here's I'll stop and sort
of take any questions that people have
might have thus far before we go into
what's new we'll go into it soon so this
they're all right give ciphertex right
predicts in the scheme of I guess I
protects the genius w only happens in
the introduction of the secret key and
then you know that so you work with it
during bootstrapping and then comes back
to I gave and then so on and so forth
right yes and I see and okay and you're
probably gonna make this ring ring
interviewee site tax or or not really
yeah that's exactly going there are two
choices right either the rocket
ciphertext could become ring lwe or the
GS w could become so I will just move on
to the next slide which is ring packing
so yes the the regular cipher texts are
going to become are all doing but you
know just answer your question so them
so in this kimono to you know a few tfhe
and so on so that encryption scheme is
just rag of this so that's always the
case
that's how you encrypt your bits and r
SW is used only inside the bootstrapping
procedure right now Jays dead usually is
based on lwe and if you introduce the
special variant of JS w which uses a
ringer the GUI by again so this is just
internally and that's also similar to
the type of ring addressed objection you
later so use the THD and now there is
one more use of ring lwe and this would
be wrinkled w/e not ring is ring the
gist debut which is what she will
introduce now and yeah that's what I one
more question
this is shy can you use also this pvw
type of packing will you sort of do well
w e but you use many secret keys to
encrypt many secrets so no so we're just
going to use a single sort of like
packing key so we knew something is
essentially a variance of keys switching
to to take sort of like let's say D
order D here where D is gonna be like
the dimension of the ring that we're
going to pack into do you how many
ciphertext and you'll just end up with
an r w encryption so what you're
suggesting is something that is useful
to for compression to get a smaller
recycle text now that's not enough so
that do strap in these amortized
bootstrap in majestic is going to
describe also requires some algebraic
structure in the cipher text so you
cannot just replace these ranges that
you ring lwe packing with the pvw it's
not just the compressing in fact the
primary
too distracting he said to amortize the
operations and get better algorithms
okay thank you Thanks any more questions
before I proceed
Jessica so there is a question in the
Q&A I think I can answer that
oh okay feel free to yeah interrupt if
if I should yeah respond anything okay
so right so we have our dlw a ciphertext
that we can presume that just come out
of some sort of homework and gate a few
and now we want to pack them into a
single rlw substrate so we define this
subroutine pack which takes the
collection of cipher texts as well as a
special packing key which will be you
know our lwe encryptions and there's
some new polynomial key C you know Q
material I won't actually throw up the
particular computations I feel like if
you're familiar with packing techniques
it's sort of intuitive you have an idea
of what we'll be doing and if you're not
then I don't think that algebra is
particularly informative but the idea is
that you know the output of this this
routine will be a single rlw a
ciphertext right more and more in terms
of standard standard ring when we should
assume that to use some sort of power of
two so that this is actually a ring of
integers like a field and the
correctness property that you would
expect right so if we perform our as of
Union friction using the key that we
used to encrypt the values of our
packing genie that we'll end up with is
a noisy
message where this message is now
polynomial the coefficients of which are
just the bits that we are encrypting
with our array of style all doing
encryptions great so now that we've done
this packing we still need to do
bootstrapping right so we still need to
homo more quickly compute decryption but
now rather than needing to compute they
do these inner products we now need to
compute a
polynomial multiplication as well as the
subtraction scaling rounding steps but
we were shown how to do these already by
Daniella and Leo so really it just sort
of remains for us to show how to
efficiently do this multiplication we
have the 1 plus epsilon homomorphic
operation sort of like at our disposal
to meet our goal of mount until the
epsilon amortized operations vertex and
so this looks pretty good right like we
know that we can perform polynomial
multiplication and and log n so it seems
like we have some some little ring here
but again if you want to sort of use
these accumulators that's going to limit
the number or the kinds of operations
that we can perform as well as the way
that we can associate those operations
so I'm sort of talk about those
restrictions a little bit and so what
how face would have informed me with an
algorithm design here so what are the
atomic became a linear operations that
we were allowed to assume so we can
initialize an accumulator with some sort
of a known plaintext manager mod Q we
can also increment an accumulator again
by some sort of known integer we can add
2 to 2 meters so maybe not know I know
value in this case get a correct
accumulator if the result of the
addition and we can perform instruction
as I mentioned before we can extract
from simulator and lwe ciphertext tell
that same value and again and of the
form needed to continue performing these
these human gates there is sort of an
additional consideration which is that
for this accumulator addition that
Association of our inputs will actually
matter - so let's say we want to add to
accumulator with Aaron beta0 and beta1
respectively I will end up later that
has error increased by a factor Dean
we're ganges about do you or do you sort
of like phone the security parameter and
it's asymmetric in the city that's right
you can see here that the area that we
get at the end sort of just like hits
our second impulse to to Edition so this
means that if we have you know two
accumulators again we know that one is
significant noisier than the other we
want to cross the noisiest one and
that's sort of the first argument and
the most amazing the second so in terms
of structure of circuits that that's
going to sort of limits the recursive so
if we have something that's for like
sort of every addition gate is taking in
as what's the results of a gate from
previous layer then we're going to end
up with error that's exponential in the
depth of those circuits so if we have
some sort of log n depths log in depth
circuit for computing justification
we're gonna end up with area that's and
that's not wearing it for great once
they slowly in so we want circuit sort
of look look more like this possible so
questions about anything so far okay
strength from this is it possible to
modify the accumulator to change the
ring that is used in GSW so I guess I
was sort of want to ask a clarifying
question do you mean like can we use a
non power to cyclotomic within the GSW
based accumulator is that what you mean
perhaps you can continue and I will sort
of let us say like preemptively so there
there's some detail some sort of hiding
under the rug a little bit so I I maybe
that's sort of what this question is
about I'm not sure okay great so so
you're gonna you're the ring that you're
gonna want to use for your little
morphic accumulator it's going to sort
of be be tied to the modulus that you
are using for your lwv ciphertext sense
if you're all familiar with what's
healthy sort of accumulators are going
to work we're going to be encoding the
values for accumulator is in the
exponent of the cipher texts and so and
we're sort of going to be using like
using this dimension as sort of like
you're using like sick powers of X to
see represents like different values
modular Q and so we won't have like
total flexibility and picking resonators
it's also sort of maybe important to
point out that I've have spoke some
details under the rug we won't actually
be packing into power to secure comics
for reasons that I can sort of refer to
you later when we start looking at the
algorithm so we'll actually be using
power three six comics but this change
is very very little instead of making it
just adds a little bit of rope am doing
the error analysis but mom doesn't
really change anything structurally so
just one was power to simplicity of
presentation so moving on so what does
this mean for candidates the polynomial
multiplication schemes so the fast
Fourier transform is going to be right
out right this is a log into
sort of computation so that's gonna be
this quasi-polynomial error even though
that's kind of sort of our requirements
for a number of market operations on the
other hand if we try to be you know less
clever about how we compute our Fourier
transform and just sort of to you like a
straightforward computation of all of
those sums will stay within the
polynomial error regime but we'll end up
having to perform something like
quadratic number operations and so we'll
get no savings for attempted
amortization and the same thing holds
for say like naive polynomial
multiplication error but this quadratic
number of operations so what we're gonna
do instead is something that sort of
combines all ideas from from all of
these logarithms so we'll be using
enough Amin transform followed by so at
least going into this this track form
was new to me so assume it's sort of
first the first pass or a high level
description of what this transforms when
to allow us to do before I get into how
it does it so it's one operate on
elements of this ring right just
goodness this is where our cipher texts
are living and it's gonna be
parameterize by some epsilon right so
again you can think of songs being less
than or equal to 1/2 and further we're
going to require that do you to be
absolutely honest if I D the dimensional
during so that's one fix we can define
some second ring our prime smaller
dimension right specifically smaller by
a factor D to the epsilon and then this
one or transform is going to allow us to
sort of reduce the task of multiplying
in our first ring R to the task of two
performing two to the two T to the
epsilon multiplications in this smaller
ring R Prime
so should we like you know excited about
this so if we you know if we're perform
these multiplications
we have something like like a slow and I
use multiplication algorithm right
things in multiplications and then this
ring will take give it to
- - epsilon so since we've lost this to
epsilon we should be happy kind of to
eat this factor of due to gasoline right
we've still reduced the total number of
operations required to perform the
multiplication well warmer this is you
can perform is right so if we're
reducing multiplication and wandering to
multiplication in the second ring with a
similar in structure then we can just
apply this again right and this will
bottom out after actually actually 1
over epsilon minus 1 but order 1 over
epsilon many recursions
and so this is going to give a constant
rate so we're aiming for actually bottom
out in this ring r double prime right
where our elements are now we mentioned
G to the epsilon so now we're gonna if
we go all the way down to the bottom so
I end up with 2 to the 1 over epsilon do
to the 1 minus epsilon many
multiplications in the small brain so
you know end up with some idea the 1
plus epsilon many operations to compute
this compute all those multiplications
and the transform itself takes the same
on the order at the same number of
operations to compute so this is going
to this is going to be our approach is
what we're going to use to do a vacation
about how this actually works as reviews
up here at the reference rate these are
just the definitions like our an R prime
when our prime sort of the ring that we
get after one layer it's a transform and
we're gonna consider the formulas
transform on some column in a way I see
that I'm out of time so I'll try to try
to speed up Jessica you can take a few
more minutes
Thanks okay so so how does this like
math work so I want to give an example
so be concrete and fix
to be equal to half and let's just say
to use 16 okay your purchases so we have
polynomial here and there's a purely
representational math there's natural
computation involved in this where we
sort of introduce a new variable Y right
where we're identifying Y with X to the
D to the epsilon and now we just rewrite
a as a bivariate polynomial here in both
x and y right so you sort of peel off
all terms that are here that are
congruent to 0 mod of epsilon and
similarly congruent to 1 and 2 and 3
right so so we now have this beautiful
bivariate polynomial now we can consider
performing a dfq on the polynomial just
an X right so if we again just
considering opposed to pulling on your X
well that's going to be our DFT of
dimension to date the epsilon and we can
perform this DFT because in this ring we
have Y as Y to the D to 1 minus 2
epsilon will be the appropriate
principal root of unity and in our
concrete case where epsilon is equals
your half this is just fine right so Y
is going to be the principal root of
unity that we need in the ring to
compute this this transform moreover in
multiplications by this rate of unity
are just going to be negative rotations
of the coefficient vector right so I'm
multiplying by y1 3 hits our Y to the
dealer 1 minus epsilon which is just
negative 1 and so we're essentially just
rotating our coefficient vector and
negating over so times so this can be
done efficiently and doesn't involve any
sort of like multiplication by a scalar
values so after we perform this D of T
we still need to perform the point wise
multiplication stuff and this is going
to require rate so the output is we're
going to end up with 2 DV epsilon
polynomials they now have degree less
than D 1 minus Epsilon
and again as I said we do this
recursively right so we end up with a
whole bunch of polynomials but now
they're they're much smaller something
like you the epsilon and we can use my
use multiplication now we can we could
have believed that that quadratic factor
that we'll get from so multiplication so
any questions so far so I have like
details namely when I talked about the
sort of these human later operations
specifically that there wasn't scalar
multiplication in since a lot of time
I'm sort of just gonna like breeze
through this because this will probably
be familiar to another people but the
way that we're going to sort of
encryptor to compute these these
multiplications that it can be required
for this so multiplication stuff at the
end is to take advantage of the fact
that okay well we know what is rather
should say that we can encrypt since the
is the user the scheme will know that s
is they can sort of provide some extra
information to their untrusted person to
their delegating the computation that
will allow this person to perform the
necessary scalar multiplications
specifically will not just give the hand
over as our bootstrapping key
accumulator storing the values transform
will give them the output of this
transform x all powers of two right that
will sort of set them we associate the
operation that is sort of taking the
binary representation with a and its
inner product with a vector of
increasing powers of two so that now we
can just take sums of accumulators since
all of these a sub J's will just be a
binary value series or ones so that's
sort of how we're getting around the
fact that we don't really have scalar
multiplication that's on the
confirmation great so sort of when a
wish
got you know a little bit into this
let's transform we want to back back up
to sort of consider why we did all this
so again our starting point was this hue
homomorphic pant we wanted to be able to
refresh these in a more efficient way so
we will pack gates into a single or LW
ciphertext perform this service one
where transform and then at the ends
will perform the multiplications by uh
some sort of naive there's a little
multiplication algorithm and just will
again give us the desired number home or
PG human operations once we consider
this amortized over all of the vertex
being refreshed and then the remaining
steps bootstrapping just sort of follow
from the results and the damn fifteen
paper so we have to perform subtraction
surrounding an extraction but that's
that already exist for us because we're
using these one more big accumulators
and again because we only had a constant
recursive depth this algorithm we only
induced a polynomial and overhead so we
get security based on hardness of
approximating these last problems to the
polynomial factors there are some open
questions notably it would be great to
get some sort of optimization that's
third remember parameters there are some
interesting trade-offs between different
choices
Absalon right so if we take a smaller
epsilon we get larger errors because we
have a larger recursive depth but we
also end up the smaller polynomials at
the end and so that's so much patience
that will go much faster there's just
the question of this areas there's some
sort of like happy way that we can still
get Polliwog we can actually drive it
all the way down to probably not create
complexity without exceeding this it's
not clear how you would do this with
their interesting a question is the
security of our lwe with binary secrets
I sort of skipped over keep switching
stuff but it has to happen at the end of
all of this what we can actually get rid
of that stuff entire me if we could
assume
security plug world we use binary bits
and lastly the canvas B you can make
these techniques be applied to tfhe rain
so the the few scheme jpg is Sarah share
a lot of structural similarities and so
it might be reasonable to think we can
do something similarities to speed up
bootstrapping and that's why I have
thank you again for sticking around
[Applause]
good you should ask and there is a
question in the Q&A and yeah okay yeah
so I think you've already answered the
first question but I'll still ask it so
about the applicability of this approach
to GF HTML 8270 basically the same
technique can be applied in women and it
looks like there is no special
constraint and prevents one just flew
from applying into the different type of
accumulator that's used in cases yeah I
would I won't think about like a little
bit more but again because the
accumulator structure is you know
essentially and so I don't yeah I don't
see why tha we couldn't support these
operations the question is what you get
out of it so the second question so the
approach that you used basically for
packing for this DFT like operation how
does it compare without say collapsed
FFT that was used for secures
bootstrapping so in the paper by how
hilarious ooh just-just-just I mean I
think conceptually there are some
similarities there where they use just
their place I 15 with the constant
physical depth computation just just
wondering more I mean how how close this
basically has power transform
collapse of ft that what uses so I
actually I'm don't think I'm able to
answer that question sort of maybe a see
if if my advisors hung around and it's
better but I'm not so I'm not sure there
is much the two things have much in
common I mean except possibly for using
the same algorithm for two different
reasons I think it may be worth a closer
look so regarding the first question
about the TFA 3 me there's a difference
so this algorithm as soon as you do it
FFT or another transform network with
more than two layers then you do need
full ring you cannot get away with
optimized you know external product
because one layer needs to feed to the
next layer so if the first layer is
computing results which are simple
Ringel degree cipher texts then they
cannot be used as input for the
following layer so it's only in the last
layer of the computation that you can
use the external product optimization so
that's one difference and so I I don't
know what you mean by a tree there's a
few in some sense
James versus AP bootstrapping that's
that's really the question is I would
say the instantiation of you with James
bootstrapping yeah so in some sense
these are completely foreign to strap in
so the bootstrapping here is different
it's doing computation so it's not clear
to me it looks more like phew because it
is using and they're folded GSW later on
is not clear how to use the how to use
the computation and this which technique
from the SAT so
the bootstrapping algorithm itself of
course you can apply to tfhe ciphertext
because they're identical I mean added a
ciphertext and also the way you compute
the basic guides
fhg a few or TFA three they're
essentially the same yeah it's not clear
how to use an external product and a
technique because accepting the trivial
case where you do only one layer by if
you do only one layer then yeah it's
Daniel Amelia's comment on that just a
little comment i Jessica sorry ilaria
here
so Daniel was saying that the the
external product sucks maybe cannot be
used but of course in tfhe you can
define also a mix with the internal just
about you
thanks just about your product so if
this is really a limitation this
operation can be defined but of course I
didn't check kind of detail to tell you
if the external product crystal because
I trust Daniella on this and basically
what you're doing is to take few then
you optimize you are removing all the
rows except one to make it more
efficient and that's the FE 3 and then
when you're doing this extension to
produce ranges that you psychotics at
the end
basically you are going back to you
you're taking all those extra rows and
putting back in so what what are you
doing it's I think conceptually can be
thought as doing and then undoing
so I'm not sure if it's something that
is distinctively you know the different
from just using few in the first place
without going through the agenda I see I
say hey it was it would be nice to to
get more into the details and and see
for the remark yes yeah it may be worth
it to tracking the details so this is my
guess
you're describing is basically two
things done in Aurora to basically bring
you back to the original original
starting point yes yes yes it was just a
comment on the milks gate - yes
absolutely
you know can I still ask the last
question the third question or is it
time it's a shorter question yes so the
third question is more on the
practicality of this technique the Hume
there is no implementation or I mean
maybe there are some estimates just to
get a idea on the concrete benefits in I
would say amortized time of using this
technique versus what's a plain fhe I
mean it's gonna be level just wondering
what what's the what's the kind of
practical I wish I had like a better
answer to give you so we did do an
implementation sort of just for like a
are you know dreamer concept type of
things so you know this works and I made
no effort whatsoever to optimize it and
so unfortunately ended up with something
with the run time was actually four
parameters that you would take for you
take four security runtimes that were
comparable to just running feel great so
you didn't actually see these are the
asymptotics kickin but I think there's
there was certainly a lot of low-hanging
fruits in terms of implementation so
there's their different choices of
Epsilon you can even like consider to
some extent really intimate like picking
different up salons at different levels
of recursion rates like you you don't
want to take it to be like say like a
function of the dimension of the current
depths because then you'll end up with
really a deficit depends on on Deans and
error but you could maybe like switch to
a different constant or something so I
think there's a lot that you could do
but they're they're existent
and it's not a particularly impressive
lower than the original few so in some
sense there was no concrete you know
benefit so in some sense you can think
of it has been a borderline practical
point in using it because you don't get
any benefit but I think if promised unit
seems that with some more effort either
on the code inside ideas might be useful
technique to substantially improve the
amortized complexity of the few / dfhi
you guys so to the whole question boils
down to whether there is a circuit for
FFT that has low lopsided depth let's
call it that yeah a circuit I assume you
guys really thought about it and they
you know there is there any kind of
lower bound you know there are no
circular ones but movies are medic is
there reason to believe that you can't
do better than this this D to the
epsilon so I don't have evidence one way
or the other again it sort of
interesting rates at if you if you try
to drag these things down to what's to
be that you seem to keep on being forced
into some sort of a polynomial error
regime again like they're at least lot
about you know different ways that you
could perform dislike recursion and the
most bummer transform and there's
there's no you know sort of treat
Absalon as being since you're like
function rather than a constant there's
nothing that gets you fired and it's not
I'm not sure in terms of like just
generally computing this phone in the
multiplication structurally or how you
do this you know in a sort of excuse er
get with modest recursive depth again
without
yeah either ending up words like the
nest won't transform that we ended up
with or you know if you have like a
completely Caesar get something that's
gonna be like quadratic clean money
operations I don't have a lower bound
that would be a really interesting
question in the Q&A looks like there are
two I think heard one was there to go oh
okay so one just disappeared and one is
I can you say more about how to choose
this point to change over from the nest
farmer transform - absolutely so again
this is going to be you know sort of a
question of what you take epsilon to be
so it seems reasonable so if you don't
care about about error at all you know
maybe you're just like happy to sustain
the polynomial regime you don't care
about what polynomial you end up with
then you you really want to recurse as
much as you possibly can right which
would be like 1 over epsilon because
this is going to give you the smallest
possible polynomials we're performing
this multiplication with a quadratic
quadratic time algorithm and so right
this is going to be sort of like the
sticking points for the ultimate like
complexity of this algorithm so this
again if you don't care about what
polynomial you meant upwards then
there's no reason to not refers to the
bottom and again like you sort of bought
them out when you lose so if you do care
about error if you say oh I particularly
a small polynomial then okay maybe you
take out some larger you can't take
epsilon to be a half and then you know
you end up with you still say like a
square root factor in your total
complexity and error but it's not
variations tend to be very cumbersome
and really it seems like for most people
efficiency of bootstrapping is sort of a
primary concern people are
I'm more or less happy to take on the
dreary so we're way over time but but
let's thank Jessica again and all this
because today and all the speakers for
the for the whole workshop thanks for
doing this in this unusual format and
thanks to all the attendees for sticking
around
let's thank the seeker once again
[Applause]